some of the photos making use today
number three top photo an extremely rare
white humpback whale thought to be a
famous one named [ __ ] Lou appear
alongside a black come back off the
coast of New Zealand now maguro hasn't
been seen for years so if a biopsy
sample confirms that it is indeed [ __ ]
Lou it would be his first sighting
outside Australian waters they took a
sample I'm looking Hugh how do you do a
biopsy sample of something that I just
wonder like what is it like to be a
creature where that's so rare that when
you show up people take little pieces of
flesh to confirm that you are you that
sounds really annoying this is where
again which actually this is the first
time that he's been spotted outside of
Australia sometimes so very interesting
next all right number two in melbourne
australia we're sticking with that
continent plans for a skyscraper were
released the design firm said in a press
release the building is inspired by
guess what um I'm not gonna let you
guess it's beyonce's song ghost shows
the singers curves can you see them
there we're looking from the ground up I
hesitated Brandon Bob anything we say
will be used against us yeah i'm at the
burger HR light is on above up yeah the
student should we move on that's her by
the way across skyscraper again the
first role of avoiding HR violation is
not to say the word HR violation on body
shapes to mud wrestling how about that
number one top photo gonna leave it
there nope in hines park destroyed five
thousand children playing in a 75 foot
wide 150 foot long pool of mud i love
this picture thousand gallons of water
and 200 tons of topsoil that's how you
make a big mud cool i love it but you
know i love it 90 degrees so there's a
mud king in a mud queen and they're
crowned as well every deer fly came off
like her boobs I would just say I was
gonna say this is a little something
that we in the Greeley household call
saturday market isn't this thing
something judge me yes exactly